Steve Wilkos well a man who's no
stranger to drama that's for sure
welcome yeah yeah yeah do you have drama
in your personal life like do you get to
a point where you're doing you're
entering your thirteenth season of this
show yeah
do you go like I deal with this
literally all day every day I need to
come home and not have this going on
right you don't like in my family I
finally have a lot of drama I mean I
have two teenagers so I mean that's a
pain in the ass other than that you know
do you try to Steve Wilkos them are you
different no in disciplinarian at all my
wife is so I'm racing you know the dead
that they come to when they want
something cuz they know they're gonna
get it my wife is the one that's really
tough on the kids I'm not I I don't
discipline them at all we get paid to
this when people don't you get tired of
people's problems or try be nice cuz
they probably always everyone probably
comes to you look I'm having this
problem my wife yeah you know
surprisingly nobody does your advice
that's well you know it's probably
fortunate in the long run for you that
you learn to deal with all that because
you didn't have like been a police
officer you know you're answering you
know calls all day long dealing with
people's problems you really don't want
to cut and truthfully it was even work
more worse I'm AM terrible English sure
no I was probably these weren't more
worse okay so was a cop
you know you'd come home and that people
be like my buddy I got a parking ticket
you know can you take care of it I'm
like no we all do that we have a cop
front like I had a vehicular homicide
and I was asking my friends for me I
backed over a couple of people the baby
just crawled in the middle your police
officer and you go to a party there's
always somebody there telling you what
[ __ ] cop they ran into right and I'm
like who cares like
how many Mormon stories here yeah I was
uh I was here there was a story this
morning on the news that the cops it
might have been in Long Island some some
spot near here the cops are pissed off
because whoever's in charge is trying to
their have they have a shortage of
crossing guards and they're going we'll
just use the cops and the chief is going
like no we need that cops to do cop
stuff you get the cops
crossing guard when I was a police
officer we didn't really how long 12
years Cardinal but we did do traffic
like you got assigned to like Cubs games
Bears games Bulls and so you if nobody
volunteered and when traversing already
saw if you were low on I'm told mole of
rookie you got assigned to that day to
what through traffic well because I was
becoming so well known on the Springer
Show it was really hard for me to be
effective police officer because the
last time I ever pulled anybody over it
was I was going I was going on furlough
and I was working by myself it was at
night and I pulled over this group of
guys they were gangbangers and I was
working by myself and I'm like I should
just let these guys go and just go enjoy
my vacation right yeah like why am I
doing this but I'm like it wasn't my
blood I knew something was going on I
had to pull him over pull my gun out I
grabbed the dry round I stick my 357
those ribs he's like were they arrested
or no no I got them all out of the car
and they actually weren't doing art they
didn't have license plates on the car I
remember that and I could have grown for
that but I'm like man I just get out of
here I'm I'm going through the station
and leaving
did you ever have situations where
you're like where you're like I need you
I'm a I'm a cop I need you to take me
seriously and stop asking questions
about the lesbian cousins they were you
know so chairs in each other we had a
big we had a woman gang fight and they
were just cut each other up and I pull
up and the fights just stops and these
girls are bleeding they're coming up and
[Music]
we're gonna have you stand on the street
and that's all you're gonna do for your
die like there'll be no problems because
right no interested you know that your
ears okay they don't want to give you
[ __ ] because they like you and they like
the [ __ ] yeah maybe my job real easy
but going back to the point that I just
totally got off of so because of what I
was becoming so well known I start
volunteering for the details that Cubs
games directing traffic and stop because
done I wasn't put into position of
having to lock anybody up right it got
harder when they like you yeah but then
I found out like I don't know why senior
guys didn't want these details because
like you go to a Cubs game it's a 7
o'clock game say right you show up at 4
o'clock you go to roll call then they
say come back at 6
do whatever you want and then you know
you direct traffic to the game start
7:00 then you come back the 7th inning
you go wherever you want so I come home
my wife make me soup like when I was a
cop so even though Trevor is bad you
probably had rabid Cubs fans yelling
[ __ ] out your oh my god I mean it was
crazy but the great thing was first of
all I'm a big guy you know yeah so
nobody ever gave me a hard time you know
and plus I was a cat so but being a
spiritual people love the Springer Show
it you know I get the occasional really
nutrish with trailer park away from oh
my God thank God if I would have stayed
on Springer all those years of kept area
net I probably would have killed myself
you know yeah so at what point did you
go I can't be a cop anymore I can't do
my time to show business
so my wife who you know she was working
on the Springer Show and she's now my
executive producer we've worked together
for 25 years she didn't understand the
whole cop thing right so one day I came
home and I was covered in blood my
uniform was I'll torn up remember what
it was from yeah always just trying
fighting this big dude you know he was
uh he was in a mental like house where
they you know people like have mental
problems and the guy was like six foot
eight and you know like Shaquille O'Neal
and they went they said he was tearing
up the place so they sent me alone smart
I'm like no way man I get on the radio
he goes uh me some people well this
woman cop came and she starts walking
the room and I grab I go where do you
think you're going just go so sometimes
they just need to hear mom's place I go
woman who works her called and she's
asked me to deal with my man and his
mother I'm like okay go ahead I go I'm
like getting ready cuz I know I'm gonna
have to go on and say we're sure enough
she starts cool and I run in and this
guy was like a cartoon now at the time I
you know when I got my police leather
jacket my gun my bulletproof vest
everything on I probably weighed 275
pounds right this guy picked me up threw
me across the room I hit the wall and
it's old plaster wall it was like the
cartoon yo che slid down behind the
couch like I fell behind this couch like
the guy just tossed me boom and then he
was like a bull and he charging and I'm
staying behind his couch like I'm you
know and he the couch hit my hand and
like it pressed against the wall and um
I broke my head so now I I jumped on the
guy's back I'm putting him in a
chokehold he's spinning around she runs
out of the room of course you know and
so I'm on my own well then you know
finally like five guys run in a room we
get this guy
come home and you know my wife's like
what the hell happened to you
I go you realize not everybody says you
know here take me to jail
you gotta fight him you know she goes
this is not you know you need to give
this up she goes listen she goes when
the Springer shows are over and this
when it still had another 20 years in
its and we didn't know she goes we're
not staying working as policemen I'm out
gonna be a policeman's wife she goes I'm
a TV producer and I begged of money I
don't want to because listen we're gonna
go to New York I'll a look that I know
that I would someday get my own TV show
and become as big as I did I'm the
spiritual so that's when I left was she
was like listen and that was making good
money on Springer and you know she's
like listen man thought that's a tough
decision though because it was a Chicago
cop for 30 years and at the time when I
left I hit like 11 a half years my dad I
was thinking so many people sign up for
the cops in a big part of it is because
that pension is coming up in Chicago
that's like 30 years anywhere else but
yeah when you're like so you know almost
everybody I grew up with is a copper
fireman right and my dad was a cop and
all our dads were cops and firemen or
garbage man or whatever all city jobs
where you know you don't have a great
education but you know you get a good
job you get a pension but when you get
exposed like I did to TV which was kind
of a fluke II thing and all of a sudden
I'm making triple for a part-time job
compared to what I'm doing full-time
you're like a man what that you know
you're going there buy your lunch
they're giving you a company car you're
like man I'm in the wrong business yeah
do you remember as a copy come on your
rookie you're eager do you remember the
first fight you had a computational the
first saw I'm a probationary alpha it
means I just came out of kidding me I'm
signed to the 13th district
in Chicago is that a good neighborhood
no it was the woods treatise the old
Chicago Stadium so Henry Horner homes
this up we literally are getting it I'm
getting in a squad car for the first
time of my career and a call comes on
the radio you know there's this guy he's
won it he's is playing a building and
what happened this guy took a pan of oil
heated it up an important I'm his
girlfriend oh my god looks like the cold
but he was somebody spotted them he was
wanted he was in this building and I'm
like these guys are just testing me you
know this is a [ __ ] car we go there
and my partner this guy Chris affairs
who's my training officer goes man pull
your gun I'm like really this is real so
I got my gun out you know I mean this is
I'm two minutes into the job and we're
going through this abandoned building
and let's do chops I'm like I'm like I
almost shoot the guy because I'm okay
did you ever like how you see videos of
cops who get jumped or God you know they
get shot at or when they walk up to a
car do you ever walk up to a car had
like four or five guys in it because
that's all that story there's footage of
that remember that one guy in Texas
where he opened the trunk and he found
pot and the guy all the two guys grabbed
a training video for comment now but it
was every time you walked up I mean
here's the difference I saw that video
okay I when I pull guys over I always
had my gun out you did always and I kept
it to my side with that listen first
date time but just making a traffic stop
and there's a woman if I'm not pulling
my gun but it was at night and there's a
but even one dude in the car I just
pulled my gun out just cut through at my
side
did you ever back off that's what I'm
saying like did you ever walk like you
said the gang guys weren't doing
anything wrong the gang guys but did you
ever get that something's about to go
terribly wrong and back out because
you're by yourself
of course I mean listen here's a great
safety feature to have you know for your
personal safety service it goes off and
you know there's a lot of time and you
call for help like hey man since a few
more guys over here you know I'm listen
I might be it's what people say oh you
take for you guys to rest this guy you
damn right it does cuz I'm not paid to
go toe-to-toe I'm not a professional
sure I'm here tonight after the rust I
don't want to get hurt ya know I got
pulled over the other night coming home
from a gig and somebody said you want to
never get a ticket here's what you do
take out the registration have the
license ready hands on ten and two as
he's walking and he was walking and it
was late it was late I was coming from a
gig and he had the light and I just was
holding it like this so he saw my hands
or nowhere and I had everything and I
just gave it to I go sorry dude I was I
was going like 4525 through it to like a
main street town I go I'm sorry man I'm
tired I just want to get home and he
appreciated that so much no ticky goes
I'll give you a warning so does that is
that us does anything that's great vite
because I do that I got stopped a month
ago and same thing I put my hands on I
roll the windows down turn interior
lights on and my license out ready to go
and then it's yes or no sir and why does
that - but I had my cell phone up so the
point you made was don't say you're not
doing what you're doing because when
like I didn't like I worked in the in
the humble Park area in Chicago at the
time was really a bad neighborhood loved
it a lot of gangs so I didn't do a lot
of traffic stops because I wanted guns I
wanted drugs I want a gang bears I
didn't want to write tickets but you had
to so if I pulled you over you really
went through that like three seconds too
late right right and I'd pull some way
over there like oh I didn't go through
red light and I go so why am i pulling
you over
I might just waste my time like I don't
want to pull you over to begin with you
know but you're so blatant so I'd rather
the honesty
you'd rather that yeah man sorry I went
through that light I just what most of
the time if you were polite and just
said yeah I did it I'm sorry
like Jesse small it should have done
then it's all right right yeah you know
but you know if you tell me that I'm
lying or I'm wrong no I'm doing my job
but if your points you know obviously
right I'm sorry
you know I'm like I had to use the
bathroom okay
go on your way
what do you think happen started what do
you think happens with Chicago now
because the cops the may everyone is so
mad I was gonna say here small in your
experience how sure do these Chicago
cops have to be with the fact that
they're going like they see Jesse
Smollett now the case is closed
and the Chicago cops and the city of
Chicago the mayor are going you know
this is complete crap
well Mike we're not done we're not done
here here's the thing when this story
came out and Sarah was my pulse is there
the minute that story broke I called
Ted's [ __ ] man like that did not
happen
and turns Howard everybody believes him
well no you don't actually happen you're
an idiot the other thing people walk
around Chicago with bleach just in case
that's big magnet country's yeah
nuisance with weren't trumped Democrats
they just like New Yorkers there aren't
a whole bunch of manga people that watch
Empire in Chicago well it does so they
go what races are watching Empire
smaller Susannah watch I don't watch any
TV except on HBO and Showtime or
something and your own show no question
of the she goes I go I only watched it
to see who's advertising on my show hey
God watch the commercials and I want to
know who's my you like a comic where
you're like a picture and I said I look
like the thing from Fantastic Four
always watch my shoulders I'm Brad Pitt
so I'm okay yeah so you knew that was
[ __ ]
yeah but I said I go listen he didn't
kill anybody nobody got hurt
he didn't rob anybody but they should
before they drop the charge they should
have said hey you're gonna say that you
made it up and we're gonna drop the
charges right like I'm sorry wasted all
these police officers
right I wasn't thinking right
I apologize and a story and I don't
think anybody even the cops I think
would be okay with that he's not going
back to what we were just talking about
with traffic ticket the cops time and
you know because again nobody's hurt he
didn't murder anybody he didn't rape
anybody it's you know he told the story
and he got caught I bet you they still
would have sent him a bill though for
all those ways he's out now he's I mean
I mean you know they're not gonna do
that
they'd they wouldn't and you wouldn't
expect that if the guy which is come on
Piana
now that he's still sticking to his
story he said he was exonerated yes
vindicated indicated yeah and he's not
and even the woman that dismissed the
Fox is saying him fine that's not true
so and and and the thing now is those
records were gonna be sealed right well
now that the city's coming after you
civilly those records become unsealed so
my thing is if you're him don't you
write that check yeah you know or you
get somebody to write it for you
yeah so that you cuz if it comes out and
all those that you know it's gonna to
expose you as a big liar which everybody
knows that already anyway why do you
think that she not only dropped it but
then sealed the records didn't make him
do that we have to seal those records
because otherwise you look like you know
Mom totally and cool at first of all
she's getting investigated now because
she said she recused herself when she
didn't again what a nightmare and all
the hours and man-hours of resources are
being wasted on a guy who told a lie
yeah yeah it still happened right it's
ridiculous like we're saying outside the
robert kraft thing you're prosecuting
all these men for getting hand jobs who
cares right these aren't sex slaves no
he's being held against their will
these are old asian women that you know
this is what they do for a living
like listen I wouldn't want that for
anybody I love or care about I think you
know there's you know it's it's a key is
you know this net but we're wasting all
these police officers and detectives and
illegal searches because the guys
getting a [ __ ] right I got that video
didn't come out the last thing I wanted
jet fans are probably good they'll be
playing at all the Patriot Games when
they come at a time I'd be happy Wow but
that's it like a good point like so many
hours and like paperwork and and people
that could be going out there doing
something go back to my point like I
don't want you pull you over right
you're a red light again I want to catch
a guy with a gun alright if somebody's
doing around you know I want to make a
good arrest I don't want to waste my
time with paperwork and and and silly or
you know guys would lock up a guy with
for a joint Mike come on man we're going
to court you're making a court day cuz a
guy has a joint it stops somebody with
10 joints I'll be like give me him
because I never did the drug in my life
I accept alcohol and just put the
marijuana down the sewer you know it's
just that people go on their way I'm
like I get in one joint go smoke it who
cares you have anybody ever trying to
bribe you like any guy who was like a
Lincoln might have a different opinion
yeah fiver how much would they offer you
like what do I want for you and like
blow it off you like 50 100 bucks you
know Oh terrible right and I say go
listen you went from getting a ticket to
now you're facing a felony charge for
bribing an officer so I'm gonna pretend
that didn't happen they put it in the
wallet when they pulled over but you
have a drug yellow on me like ten
thousand dollars no I never had like
that happened nothing like no because
most of those type thing when you're
doing big you being specialized yeah
it's making those kind of rest I was
street cop so I was getting guns and
gangbangers and if it was drugs they had
you know a small amount you know you
ever miss the adrenaline rush that you
missed that I see you know when I was in
the Marines we were doing all she
doesn't man [ __ ] it hops the Marines so
like I really loved the Marines and I
was gonna make it a career but you know
I kind of missed home so I came home and
when I was a cop you you know you feel
like especially coming on the Marines I
was Superman I could do anything and so
you get a gun in a badge in your
twenties and you're in Chicago and
they're like guac
the bad guy and it was thrilling
everything getting a car like I'm gonna
get the bad guy and but that takes its
toll too and after a while you get beat
up and it just you know being a nobody
likes to please you know right that's
the thing and it's only gotten whereas
right and it's a hundred times worse
than when I was but don't you think the
body I think the body cams are good
because they exonerate a lot of cops to
you like oh yeah that guy did here's the
problem with that because if somebody
walks up and punched me in the face as a
police officer I'm going to beat you in
a pulp I was going to beat you to a pulp
I mean I was gonna stomp your brains out
you're talking to Steve makes me feel
like such a [ __ ] he's a marine cop I'm
like I what kind of a comedy club and I
wonder if the guy like my point is it's
human reaction if somebody hurts you
you're gonna want to hurt them even and
and that's what I was always trained to
do so now with these body cams if
somebody came up and spit your face you
know you'd have to show restraint you
know which you know I get it the body
cams because my thing was I wasn't doing
anything wrong I wasn't stealing bribe
and you know use and call people names
you know stuff like that I mean I did
curse when I was a police officer
but I mean I wasn't doing it to be
derogatory or offensive you know we use
usually as a command system so I
wouldn't have problem with body camera
but what I'm saying when you're in a
physical altercation you're not gonna
stop you know oh to an excessive level
you damn right cuz this guy just punched
me in the face we tried to kill me yeah
I'm gonna give him a little tune-up they
expect you to be robots and then just
strike with the exact proper amount of
force since that's the problem with body
cam that's like that rules of war right
it's like if you see somebody up there
you they were like easily assault like
yeah oh you know well you're you know in
the Marines like well what you doing
Marines well I was trying to kill people
what do you think what years were you in
82 day the night did you go oh I just
don't know so copy there's some guys in
my platoon from boot camp that actually
unfortunately were sadly killed in
Beirut and I was lucky because I got
sent to Asian some of those guys got
sent there and was there Embassy bombing
in Beirut or no is that there wasn't
there Romanian embassy perks but that's
where the truck went and I actually
ended up working with the sergeant who
was at the gate and that was back again
when we had these ridiculous policies
where your gun couldn't be locked and
loaded you're standing guard and the
truck went flying back and these guys
didn't even have loaded weapons to shoot
this guy right that was a px Kelly it
was the Commandant at the Marine Corps
zero defect policy at the time and you
know obviously when we become serious in
times of war I mean that that stuff
doesn't happen anymore but again to your
point of guys being you know we're we're
criticizing guys in times of war and all
they did went over the line well you
know these guys are the most brutal
conditions you're supposed to kill
people and yeah you sometimes things can
get really messy and yucky it gets out
of hand
yeah but I'm most fascinated with
anybody militaries that you make it
through boot camp I get so tired make it
through Parris Island well I couldn't do
it if that was any older than 18 right
because I tell guys all the time like
I'll see guys that you know they go to
college for a couple years
they get fat and lazy and then they're
like I don't want to go I'm gonna join
the Marines they go good luck we had
high school I played sports I was in
decent shape and I was like oh my god
I'm gonna say I'm gay or did drugs this
is 1982 I'm gonna get out of here
there's no way I'm like this is nice
yeah but they let us sleep for like an
hour and then I woke up I'm like okay I
think I can make it I actually love
being in the Marines but man it's it's
no joke man it was brutal how long is it
brutal for is it like that it was it
almost three months
oh it's three months months with boot
camp you know brainwashed right you're
getting brain well you're starting to
change mentally right yeah not
brainwashed
sorry yeah all right next one in the
interview all right so uh you know
communists Paul you can count it one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM Avenue